the UK's Finance Minister says the
British arm of the failed American Bank
svb has been bought by HSBC Holdings
it's the latest ripple effect from the
crisis that began when the bank went
bust on Friday meanwhile U.S President
Joe Biden is set to address the impacts
on the banking sector in a speech later
on Monday the federal government has
announced emergency action to shore up
deposits and cushion the financial
Fallout of the biggest bank failure in
the country since 2009. the U.S federal
reserve and treasury say the bank's
customers will have access to their
deposits U.S officials also say that
they'll be supporting depositors of
Signature Bank which they revealed was
closed by New York Regulators on Sunday
serious Roslyn Jordan reports now from
Washington D.C
the U.S government took control of a
bank that did a lot of business with
cryptocurrency firms on Sunday this
comes after the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank in California on Friday the
U.S President Joe Biden released a
statement late on Sunday saying that he
had ordered the federal government to
make certain that the customers of both
Signature Bank and New York State and
Silicon Valley Bank in California would
get all of their money this is a big
deal because normally when you have an
account with a U.S Bank the insurance
only covers the first two hundred fifty
thousand dollars however the emergency
program now being launched by the
treasury Department and other Federal
economic agencies will cover all of the
customers deposits in those two banks
that way the people who use those Banks
to run businesses for example can pay
their bills and make payroll now there
is a lot of a controversy already over
this emergency program even though the
federal government says that this will
not be a cost to taxpayers some
economists say ultimately this this cost
will be passed on to taxpayers and to
banking customers there are others who
are saying that it is important for the
US government to prevent a run on other
Banks if customers have more money than
250 thousand dollars deposited in those
institutions they say it is critical to
keep the U.S economy on a steady footing
the U.S president does note that there
is growing concern about the situation
with the banking sector and he told
reporters on Sunday evening that he's
going to talk to the Nation about it on
Monday
well svb mostly provided Financial
Services to flinchling companies in the
tech sector the bank claimed to support
nearly half of all venture-backed
startups in 2022 but after svb's
collapse many of those startups are now
in trouble unable to access their funds
that are facing difficulty paying
salaries and meeting operating costs
well it's mostly Tech firms at risk svb
is also involved in other sectors it
loaned around four billion dollars to
the wine industry and now thousands of
wineries are locked out of their
accounts meanwhile in the UK and the EU
there are fears that the Ripple effects
of the svbs collapse May spread the UK's
Chancellor Jeremy Hunters warning of a
serious risk to domestic Tech firms
Economist and financial analyst Robert
Scott says the federal reserve's raising
of interest rates led to the issues in
the banking sector
the vote has an obligation treasury in
the FDIC actually in this case the ones
who made the announcement they have an
obligation to protect depositors in the
banking system uh but that begs a larger
question is the Fed going to get the
message and slow down this program of
tightening of the interest rates in the
economy the concern is that the FED is
going to pitch the economy into a
recession that will cause millions of
job bosses and that will hit the poorest
uh and the the hardest the black and
brown workers who will lose their jobs
first uh the wealthy and Powerful who
own the corporations that are benefiting
from these kinds of bailouts will not be
hurt they'll keep their jobs they'll
keep earning profits uh it's it's
low-income workers who will suffer as a
result of these tight fed policies